i'm firmly of the mindset you should
never pre-order a game ever no no never
no no no matter how good or 100 it looks
like amazing or the bonus deals don't do
it it's a bad practice and i think it's
bad for gaming
it is here we go here we go for gaming
man it's sharks
i mean it's because like i'm not into
gaming as much as i used to be and even
back then i just i don't think i've ever
pre-ordered a game or at least like i
think the only game i ever tried
pre-ordering was gta but that was just
like because it was gta oh yeah do you
remember like it was like 2 000 picture
2013 everything is a pre-order bonus
yeah literally like everything is
pre-order like no everyone is
pre-ordering everything that's just how
it is you pre-order [ __ ] everything
but luckily now everyone's chilled out
but it was insane but i also think kind
of back then it made more sense right
because back then the game you're buying
on the day was the game you were getting
right there was no updates no patches no
nothing and it also made more sense
because we it's just i think it really
hit its peak right
before maybe just during online shopping
started popping up right right you know
and this is before when you didn't
really want to download it people's
internet speeds probably weren't good
enough to really get download a full 20
gigabyte game yeah like that but now you
know people's internet speeds it's not
really a problem yeah and also back then
i feel like you just had a lot less
choice of what games you could play you
know as a kid i'm just like yeah i
waited like four [ __ ] five months for
the new mario game because there was
nothing else to look forward to there
was literally nothing to fulfill that
void i couldn't i couldn't get a
free-to-play game like genji
playing games
like like fortnite or league of legends
or anything like that there's nothing to
fill that fill up that voice the only
games that i've pre-ordered are the ones
that like i know 100 i'm going to love
i've ordered every single like mario
release of late and i haven't played any
of them
well that sounds like your problem i
don't know
because i think the last game i
pre-ordered was uh final fantasy 7r but
i 100 of that because i knew i was going
to like it because i like the original
and like persona 5 royal as well i
pre-ordered that because yeah i liked
the persona 5. i mean i i've i have so
many [ __ ] games that i've bought in
my library that i just have
i've downloaded them i've installed them
and i just never know for them i've
never opened them what was the last time
you got really hyped for a game
final fantasy 7r probably did it live up
to your hive yeah 100 percent of it what
are you going to fantastically order the
game and it got very exciting i haven't
pre-ordered it like the last time i got
hyped for a game cyberpunk
i'm not joking that was the last time i
got hyped for everybody
everybody laughs
and you know what i still haven't even
played it i beat cyborg i
[Music]
because i was just like great it's a
sci-fi game it's cyberpunk this looks
like everything i've ever wanted to fill
up that void that mass effect has just
left for let me left me for years and
now that
like every few months i just google is
cyberpunk 2077
it was like cyberpunk is nowhere near a
no man's sky turn around
brutal the devs are like we're nowhere
near fixing it like no man's sky
or something like that
according to something like that i was
really it
they had to say a no man's sky turn
around yeah of course i mean that that
is like no man's sky is the [ __ ]
anime redemption of the gaming industry
i think it's like one of the only
redemptions that's when the antagonist
turned into the protagonist
because most companies you just cut your
losses and you're like [ __ ] it make the
next [ __ ] fallout yeah yeah like 76.
make a new one yeah you know it's it's
when was the last time you got hyped
yeah as the gamer
borderlands 3. i was very happy for
borderlands 3
no all right i was extremely hyped for
borderlands absolutely borderlands 2 is
one of my favorite games yeah because i
was gonna ask i've never played three
but i've played two and two which is
great i haven't played boardwalk what
was the sigh there gone i just i just
realized i just realized what the game
before okay
2077 what the last game i was hyped
before that i bought lens too right i
loved borderlands uh so i bought
borderlands one originally on xbox 360.
and uh i thought it was [ __ ] i hated it
because i didn't have friends to play
with so it was terrible
went back to it gamepl later my friends
bought it went on more more sale i just
went cheaper sorry uh and yeah i loved
it and i thought wow this okay this game
is actually sick when you play it with
friends then borderlands 2 came out and
it looked like they just improved
everything yeah and they did yeah and it
was amazing bought lens 2 is such a good
game and playing it with friends is like
amazing like this this game is so much
replay value with friends um and i
absolutely had like some of the best
gaming memories playing board lens too
so naturally borderlands 3 was coming
out and i had a monster gaming pc yeah
that was ready every all my friends were
getting it there's endless people i
could play with it was going to be good
yeah
so i play it and uh yeah it's just kind
of like borderlands 2 but with like a
worse story like the stuff they add
isn't very good wait since when have you
[ __ ] cared about story well
borderlands 2 actually was such like
handsome jack is such an uh engaging
villain oh yeah
you don't care about the story he's
there always making you laugh right and
that was something that even if i didn't
care what was happening i knew that i
liked handsome jack and then he was
funny as [ __ ] and i loved having that
and the two main villains were like
youtubers or twitch streamers in the
third one right and it was just cringe
because i'm a youtuber and twitch
streamer right so is cringe watching i
am the bad guy
it was like yeah
it was just like poking fun at me in
like the worst way right and i was like
this isn't this isn't the representation
i asked for
slander
i'm all down for when people make fun of
youtubers and twitch streamers i'm all
down for it but sometimes they do it in
like a like a wasteful way in a way
never watched something because there
are so many other things you could have
gone for like you know they do the whole
thing of like oh hi guys whatever and
they could have gone for like why don't
you thank me for like the 10 donation or
something like that right that would
have been funny as [ __ ] you know like bo
burnham did a great parody of it i mean
bye-bye used to be a youtuber oh yeah
obviously he did a great parody of
twitch streamers and stuff and that was
great but i felt like it was a terrible
parody
and it was also they were just so
unlikable and there was so many bugs in
it as well like there were so many
game-breaking bugs that just happened
throughout i was like this shouldn't be
happening i waited years for this
i got hyped for this i felt invested in
this give my high back also i didn't
really like any of the characters that
you could play as yeah which kind of
sucked borderlands 2 i felt like every
single character was like pog yeah
because like the game i think the the
game the game i got hyped for before
cyberpunk
was uh this this just shows my track
record and why i don't get hyped for
games anymore right it was mass effect
andromeda i thought you might say
fallout 76 yeah i thought you might
before i thought
mass effect andromeda
i love donkey's video i don't know i've
never played mass effect i've just
watched these videos on them and this
video andromeda was so funny i think
i've played like an hour of mass effect
andromeda and i'm just like this this
this just isn't doing it for me right
like
by that point like i i think i think
cyberpunk was just uh yeah this looks
like a game that could be you know could
appeal to me but i think mass effect was
really what just killed my soul right
right there's something so
heartbreaking about it in a way that
i've never experienced when a game just
lets you down like that yeah yeah it
feels like your dad just never came home
you know like it's like damn but it's
like it feels like your dad came home
but with a different woman
a new son
it's just it's i could i feel like
that's the first time you get to really
experience betrayal as a young adult
yeah
a true betrayal i trusted you yeah i
followed you all the way through and
this is how you repay me i stuck with
you for years i had memories with you
that i can't i can't i've never even had
with anyone else and this
yeah it's gone like that
yeah i mean like i i just i just like
now i just try to keep as little
knowledge of the gaming industry and
like what's coming out sports well
because i've like i've kind of realized
my favorite gaming experiences recently
have just been games that i had no idea
about until they were out yeah i didn't
know anything about breath of the wild
and it blew me away yeah yeah yeah does
that know anything about breath of the
wild i'm just like it's been [ __ ]
i've played zelda since wind waker and
it was [ __ ] amazing oh yeah horizon
zero dawn i was like what the [ __ ] what
what kind of game franchise is this i
had no idea what it was about it was
[ __ ] amazing that's why i'm not
hyping myself up for breath of the wild
too right because i don't want a [ __ ]
andromeda to happen you know like god
forbid it never happens but like you
never know right so i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna wait